how's it going Brad as money's bad
today's video is a little bit different
we're gonna play two games I don't know
what's going on this is gorgeous the
depth if I actually went with my gut
when I was younger and did what I wanted
to do I probably would have wanted to do
game development cuz it seems really fun
and really exciting to work as a team
with people with the same hobby and
passion as you do on a creative product
together so super cool if you're a
younger little little guy or girl and
wants to get into this kind of thing
check out Full Sail they have a campus
equipment professional game development
thingies and labs and they also offer
online degrees which is cool so I don't
know I feel like I have a lot of younger
people who watch me and and if you
obviously care about games a little bit
so you know do what you want to do if
this sounds fun to you then do it who's
stopping you uh I think it's cool I want
to support it because I feel like I made
the wrong decisions in life and that's
why I'm here I am locked out you know
but not everyone does and and I think
it's important to do what you want to do
so there we go let's say let's check out
the first game
make me one Nance some I danced at the
club so this is supposed to be a modern
retro platformer that takes homage to
the 70's and 80's and 90's of video
games which sounds [ __ ] awesome made
by five graduates from full of sales
design master program so let's see what
they can do over there shall we
I like the chip tunes am i playing pong
what are you doing in here did I fail I
don't know what's going on I say stars
as babies or semi Dee's maybe I place
the pong ball that's kind of Awesome
pity escape ah damn it
I can never play pong again pong will
never be the same
he's the chosen one
it's the chosen pong me this looks
dangerous can I go here never mind then
all right
what oh my god stop there we go oh cool
so I was stupid I should jump from here
oh thank God it's not an unfair
platformer I'm so sick of this how do I
get up there I know here we go
seriously how oh my god
this is too intense for parents stop no
okay place place them
did I do it this is it yeah
Jania spam strikes again dammit my back
here I'm so close aah what is he doing
in the water
aah you're a lovely lady fall asleep
isn't it how are you talking to me right
now this kind of music that would just
stress the [ __ ] out of me if I was a kid
and playing this this is not the kind of
treasure this baby's head I don't know
if you call that a treasure you call
that a a60 nightmare I can't tell if he
likes it or not that's the me that's the
problem when you jump on people's lungs
they might say they like it but really
they don't now yeah yeah boy yeah boy
it's your boy it's a boy oh nice book of
our reference what bit is it bother me
all right grace care scale area what why
do you both understand okay this is
pretty [ __ ] cool they may like a new
game for each area that's awesome they
still have that thing yeah they do
oh this is gorgeous
and I like how there the music involves
with a shoe that's really oh my god
that's awesome and I wish and I
obviously wish I had time to label but
we have to end this one here that's
awesome let's move on to the next game
made by a full sail team mixed game that
we're gonna check out from Full Sail
people is Spectre and you can play over
the oculus rift so we're just we're
gonna do just that I think I've actually
played an early version of this cuz it's
like an online multiplayer online
multiplayer yet horror don't look at her
she knows you're here this is just like
real life
when I go and get a snack during the
middle of the night and Mark says out
it's literally the same thing if I look
at her she'll bite off my face this is
[ __ ] awesome I don't know if you
brothers have checked out the oculus
with a horror game but it [ __ ] I I
can't even [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god what is
going on am I looking at her what is
this I remember this I have a faint
memory of this okay I hear it whispering
what the [ __ ] is up with that stop I'm
not looking I'm never like a sad the
death ah the [ __ ] she's speaking
oh I sneak peeked don't sneak peek on
her I'm gonna get it this way okay oh my
god what's going on over there
ah all right I'm so glad it's over
oh man all right price that was awesome
look at my hair
big thanks to Full Sail University for
sponsoring this episode and aspiring
game developers we go and make some
games if you want to check out their
programs for animation and game
development the link it's in the
description
that's it